as we've been hearing the Chancellor
Philip Hammond told city leaders that
Britain is weary after seven years of
hard slog so his austerity really over
and should it be were here to tell us
her father Shaheen she's director of the
Center for label and social studies and
Daniel Mahoney is deputy director of the
Center for Policy Studies so fires start
with you Nick McPherson the former first
permanent secretaries of the Treasury
wrote in the FT last week Britain
actually hasn't had austerity do you
agree no I don't agree I think when you
look across public services so even
mental health budgets eight percent cuts
NHS schools I mean all of those parents
that got letters home from their head
teachers saying that and they don't have
enough money I mean what was that was
that not to be with the cuts and we know
nurses going to food banks the cuts have
had huge social consequences and
actually economically as well haven't
worked the way that Osborne who was the
original architect wanted them to work
so every time I've missed targets we had
the slowest recovery of recovery in
modern history
we had wages stagnating we saw consumer
debt private household debt back up to
finance a pre financial crash levels so
it has been a failure
Nick Macpherson's point though is that
government spending has carried on
rising year after year you know there
haven't been a year when it's fallen
it's risen every year the the debt to
GDP ratio has also risen from I think
seventeen six to eighty nine percent
whereas Ireland he would argue genuinely
did have austerity and it's seen its
debt to GDP ratio fall so the thing is
with the austerity policy is that it's
like looking at the telescope through
the wrong end so the way in which you
cut debt public debt is to create or
help stimulate more good job creation
which means that the tax take goes up
now we haven't seen that we've seen the
type of bad job creation through our
hours more people in precarious work and
that has meant that that tax take hasn't
come so you know it has been a failure
in the sense that you don't cut yourself
out of debt you have to try and grow
yourself out and we haven't seen that
growth in the way that we wouldn't need
to see it so Daniel Philip Hammond today
basically said people have had seven
years of hard slog should he now change
course well no he shouldn't change
course and actually he did say that we
won't change course the conservator
party has quite a modest deficit
reduction plan so it's only planning a
surplus in 20 25 26 so that would mean
we've been running a deficit for a
quarter of a century so that's the
longest period since the Second World
War so that's I'm quite quite a long
time so any softening of that program
would be a big risk to the UK and I
think when it comes to the austerity
package you know as you said I think
overall spending is is around flat I
think it's gone up slightly but it's
been very unbalanced so some
departmental budgets have faced big cuts
but other budgets so the international
aid budget pensioner benefits they've
seen quite big increases so I think I
think that sort of there needs to be a
bit of rebalancing there but I think
they were all packaged there does need
to be you know some restraint I mean the
fact that he's pushed the deficit
reduction target back to the middle of
the next decade in the mid of the next
Parliament and I mean is that because
he's assuming there's going to be lower
growth post brexit essentially I think
so in the OPR I think makes that
assumption as well I think it's slightly
unfair to criticize George Osborne for
missing his target after all in the
early part of the physical acceleration
period there was the eurozone crisis
which did have a dampening effect on
growth and I think some people argue
that fiscal consolidation you know cause
that I think the evidence very much yes
otherwise not just the eurozone crisis
there was also you know high commodity
prices and things like that so you know
they have but there has been very strong
growth since then so 2014 and 2016 very
strong growth and you know some of the
highest in the g7 so look the second
world war when we had high levels of
debt how did they get us out of that
they invested we created jobs we put
that public investment in and that meant
we paid off the debt that's a really
good example right except we haven't we
didn't pay off all war debts until a
couple years ago dramatically it came
down to members oq historically we
didn't have high levels of debt until we
bailed out the banks and the financial
crisis happened so we have to take that
into account now what you do to grow
yourself look look at countries like
Italy they have lower levels of debt
than us but are they countries we want
to be like they have high levels of jet
debt to GDP public ownership if you look
at and debt and how much they've taken
out per year it's you know so used
these countries that actually the focus
on debt is not helpful what we should be
focusing on especially a time of break
sir especially a time when we need to be
recalibrating the economy making sure we
get through this tough tough time is to
focus on growth is to focus on how to
stimulate that hat is to think about the
ways in which we can make sure we have
an economy ready for climate change for
automations those big things that are
happening and the focus on the day is
just an unhelpful way of looking at the
issue can I just say on the second world
war point I think that is a bit of a bad
news story up we're right at a time I do
apologize Pfizer Daniel thanks for
joining me both